[Applause]
thank you yes that's right that's the
name of a character kind of a love-hate
relationship there with Alan Pardew
you you created this character how many
years ago then you Ukraine in the early
90s yeah I do this character for those
who don't know I mean some of the very
cool Americans do know yeah so about
that 20 there is there is he is he is
one of the most awful - your character
is one of the worst talk-show hosts the
present company excluded I created and
to make people like you feel better
yeah I do I do 28 years ago I created
him out and I thought that and I
actually think that probably I I sort of
go away from and do other things and try
and do interesting things like stan and
Ollie and Philomena
yes can I go then they go back and off
great so yeah I should I actually I know
he started clapping that she had him I
sort of notes say no please don't
applaud even if they don't so but I
think probably when I die my epitaph
will be here at her lies Alan Partridge
yeah yeah yeah it's your very connect
with the character and obviously
multi-talented guy so you kind of want
to break free I will tell you this this
is a true story I was on a flight
not long ago British Airways flight and
they they had the latest episodes of
Alan Partridge and they come along every
now and then and I just cherished them
and I watched them and they only had
three and they I thought they were gonna
have many more they ran out after three
I was a wild man
it's as if they had told me there was no
more liquor on the flight I was swinging
and screaming I was bitterly bitterly
depressed well it leave them wanting
more
need the morning more Alan to leave
leave them in rage that's what I always
leave your audience
angry and kicked off a plane